البدايه من باريس حيث اصيب سته اشخاص في
حصيله اوليه ججر عمليه طعن في محطه قطارت
الشمال جارديارد في العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس فيما حيدت شرطه باريس منفذ الهجوم
واطلقت النار عليه لان قال الى المستشفى
واقامت حواجز امنيه عند محطه القطارات بعد
عمليه الطعن من جهتها اعلنا الشركه
القطارات الفرنسيه عوده الحركه لطبيعتها
في المحطه بعد ان اقامه الشرطه الحواجز
الامنيه
اذا مشاهدينا هذه صور مباشره من مترو
باريس من المحطه محطه قطار الشمال التي
تعرضت لاعتداء في هذا اليوم حيث اصيب سته
اشخاص كانوا في هذه المحطه الشرطه كما
ذكرنا مشاهدينا اقامه بالتطويق المنطقه
وقامت حواجز تعطر قبل ذلك حركه القطارات
طبعا في هذه المنطقه لكنها الان بدات تعود
الى طبيعته حسب شركه القطارات اذا
مشاهدينا هذه مشاهد اوليه من همم من محطه
محطه القطارات التي تعرضت لاعتداء هذا
اليوم والشرطه الفرنسيه اعلنت انها قد
حيدت المهاجم ونقل الى المستشفى بعد
اصابته اديسون مباشره الى المشاهدين من
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس بعد هذا الهجوم
على محطه قطارات الشمال كما ذكرنا
مشاهدينا سته جرحه جراء عمليه الطعن في
محطه قطارات الشمال في باريس